thank you very much so we're going to
get rid of the light to start with okay
thank you very much thank you for all
coming out on this bright although
Christmas morning to hear something
about science and what we do in my
laboratory mostly about science I'm not
going to talk so much about exactly what
we do in our laboratory but things are
going to be related so what I really
want to talk to you today is about light
and about how light interacts with
molecules and how we can learn something
about molecules from those interactions
I've given you here my email address
should you have any questions or wish to
contact me later
but of course in anything we do here at
Yale in research and teaching it's not
really only the professors that matter
right it's also the support in
particular doing research I'm very
fortunate to have a wonderful group of
students who actually do the experiments
because I can barely see things at my
age nowadays actually and so you'll see
some of my students sitting in the front
rows here they'll wave they're going to
do some of the demonstrations that I'll
show you today and what we do in my
laboratory can be classified as
molecular spectroscopy so it's going to
involve molecules and it's going to
involve spectra which is what we had
what is basically the interaction
between light and molecules so let's
talk a little bit about how I became a
scientist where I came from and my
motivations I was born about a hundred
and fifty miles from New Haven in New
Jersey the Jersey coast small town less
than a thousand people Allenhurst New
Jersey I like to call this the real
Jersey Shore right not like the
television show that young people should
not be watching clearly and so my family
we were not my family are not scientists
but they were they were very
accommodating when I started taking
televisions apart and all sorts of
things apart to quote-unquote improve
them and never got them back together so
I was always very interested in in how
things work how do you know how objects
are put together and so that really
piqued my interest in science and I must
say I've had also very supportive
teachers teachers in particular my
seventh and eighth grade science teacher
mrs. Houlihan really really was
instrumental in encouraging me to do
science so I went to high school in a
neighboring town the neighboring town is
Asbury Park
okay Asbury Park some of you might
recognize the name so I went to Asbury
Park High School neighboring town and at
the time I went to high school the
mid-70s Asbury Park was becoming the
destination for rock and roll there's
something called the the Jersey Shore
Sound which combines rock and roll with
rhythms and rhythm and blues and you
know when I was growing up literally
this guy Bruce Springsteen was a
youngster wasn't really known yet and I
got to see him certainly in concert when
nobody knew who he was
right but in 1973 he did come out with
this album all right greetings from
Asbury Park New Jersey so when I was in
high school I was very interested in
photography
okay so photography actually you know
optics life that makes sense with what I
do nowadays but let's understand
photography for many of you today you
know you take your cell phone you take a
picture you hook it into your computer
and the picture comes out photography
back then no computers right photography
you took a picture on actual film you
had to develop the film you had to make
a print so a lot of chemistry was
involved right so I got interested in
optics I got interested in chemistry how
do you make prints how do you make
pictures right and I took that with me
to college in college I took my first
chemistry class which was actually given
by a Nobel laureate and I was totally
caught right I was totally interested in
chemistry as Kurt zoom indicated at the
beginning I
and out doing researches in organic
chemists and that organic chemists had
actually a collaboration with a physical
chemist using lasers and that's how my
path got steered into optics and lasers
so I'm a physical chemist let's
understand what a physical chemist is so
first of all chemistry what is physical
chemistry while chemistry we like to
call the central science we like to call
it that because chemistry is a physical
science but it actually joins the
biological sciences or Applied Sciences
so medicine and engineering with the
physical sciences physics mathematics
and everything's chemistry is at the
core chemistry really involves anything
having atoms and molecules in it so
physical chemistry what is physical
chemistry well if you go and look it up
in a dictionary you get this branch of
science applying physical methods and
theory to the study of chemical systems
and this is true we take ideas from
physics we steal them right and we apply
them to try to understand chemical
problems but this definition is boring
right so we prefer a much different
definition first stated by a very famous
physical chemist GN Lewis and G then
Lewis defined physical chemistry as
being anything that's interesting and
that's how I like to think about
physical chemistry we take tools often
develop by other disciplines and we
apply them to try to understand chemical
problems and oftentimes we improve and
refine those tools to make them do
things people haven't been able to do
before so in this talk I'm going to tell
you about something interesting I'm
going to tell you about spectroscopy so
let's think a little bit about
spectroscopy fundamentally spectroscopy
is the interaction of light with matter
so light here means electromagnetic
radiation we're going to have to talk a
little about what we mean by
electromagnetic radiation and matter
means literally atoms and molecules and
so there are many forms of molecular
spectroscopy
I have these various cartoons will touch
on various aspects of these cartoons
throughout the talk so let me give you a
history and this is a very abridged very
brief and a very much biased towards my
opinion history of what I would call
quantitative spectroscopy and we we have
some demos that are going to go along
with this so if my first bullet point
here is Isaac Newton Isaac Newton in
1666 showed and it's sort of indicated
in this picture that you could take
sunlight pass it through a prism and
disperse it into the colors of the
spectrum okay and so we have and this
led him to conclude that color is an
intrinsic property of light and so we
have a demonstration of this over here
that my student Paul is going to show
you we're going to plug it in and here
you see what we would call white light
it's not sunlight but we'll agree that's
white light we pass it through a prism
this is not quite the prism that Isaac
Newton used although it looks that old
but it's a prism that actually has more
ability to separate the light into
colors than the one Isaac Newton had and
you can see the white light passes
through the prism and it comes out in
the colors of the rainbow ray and it's a
continuous change in color ranging from
red through orange to yellow green blue
indigo and violet so we can take white
light separate it into the colors of the
spectrum so Isaac Newton did this in
1666 he also said some ideas about what
is light oh sorry you did what did you
learn about him
mmm-hmm an apple fell on him yep so
Isaac Newton is more is known for many
things he's a very great son was a very
great scientist certainly known for
gravity certainly known for mechanics
how things move also known for
developing calculus also thinking about
light and even he was a chemist he those
are secret things that he never told
anybody
he was an alchemist he was trying to
turn lead into gold right so he did many
many things many many things but Isaac
Newton also argued that light is
composed of little particles and what
happens is as the particles pass through
something like a prism a denser medium
they're bent or diffracted this was not
the popular theory at the time where as
will see light was considered to be
waves but several hundred years later at
the beginning of the 1900s we'll also
talk about our modern idea of light is
that it is particles at least under
certain circumstances so that's our
first bullet Isaac Newton 1666 who used
the prism to disperse sunlight my next
very biased bullet is Fraunhofer Joseph
von Fraunhofer in 1814 he developed
something that replaces a prism
something I hope you all have one of
when you first came in this little
diffraction grating this little slide
that doesn't use a prism to separate the
colors of light but he actually uses a
process we call diffraction that we'll
talk about a little bit later and he
looked at the Sun you know looked at the
spectrum of solar light and what he
found is that not he didn't only see the
continuous colors I showed you here but
he also found many many dark bands
appearing in the spectrum this is a
modern version of what Ferran Hoffer saw
and
what I'm showing you here is a red AB
and going across it then continues on
this side red red red it passes through
orangey yellow green etc so you see the
continuous spectrum and all these dark
bands these dark bands we call nowadays
Fraunhofer lines and that those are
signatures of atoms and molecules in the
outer atmosphere of the Sun so he didn't
have an explanation for this from Hoffer
turned out not to really be a scientist
he was an optician he was more
interested in making instruments than
doing measurements and trying to
understand things and understanding for
what these Fraunhofer lines actually
were came in 1859 by two of German
scientist Robert Bunsen and Gustav
Kirchhoff we're and they systematically
investigated emission coming from heated
elements eventually leading them to
discover two of the elements we know
today's caesium and rubidium their
apparatus looked something like this
this is the actual apparatus they used
this is a more refined version of it but
the idea is they had a heated elements
over here going through a prism and then
observing the colours in a controlled
fashion have any of you heard of Robert
Bunsen before have you heard of the
Bunsen burner often used in chemistry
but developed to do spectroscopy right
because it made a light it made a source
of a way to heat atoms or molecules but
not to give background light that would
confuse the spectral signatures so we're
going to do a demonstration right now
the door is going to do a demonstration
we're going to heat various salts in a
flame what we're actually doing is where
we're going to put in each of four pans
here we're going to put in different
salts we're going to then put in
fuel to heat the salts the fuel we're
going to use is liquid methanol we're
going to light it on fire the methanol
provides a flame which is colorless we
heat the salts we decompose them into
their elemental forms the elements get
excited to different excited energy
levels and as they relax down they will
give out characteristic colors okay and
so we'll see this we have four salts we
have lithium chloride sodium chloride
strontium chloride and copper chloride
the characteristic colors you'll see are
coming from the sodium the lithium the
strontium the copper these are very much
the colors that you see in fireworks
fireworks are nothing more than
basically burning salts of various types
so we're putting in the salts and then
we're going to add to each of them the
fuel don't do this at home right so we
have one pan here where we have no salt
at all just the fuel why are we doing
that a control right we're going to show
you what the flame looks like when you
don't have any salt we're really loading
it up
okay let's put the fuel far away okay so
let's light the control first so you can
see the control is burning with a and
I'm going to maybe try to turn off my
screen here so you can see it better
it's burning with a light blue flame now
let's light the others
so the last one is copper characteristic
green flame
the first one is lithium nice red flame
sodium yellowish flame and strontium a
reddish orange flame right and this is
what Bunsen and kerkhof we're studying
where do these colors come from right
these colors are coming from the various
elements that are being heated and going
to excited levels and then when they
relax back down they they give out this
characteristic color those dark bands
that Fraunhofer saw on the solar
spectrum right
those dark bands are atoms in the outer
atmosphere of the of the Sun that
instead of emitting absorbed the light
that the Sun has passing through it and
we'll talk about absorption and emission
a little bit later but very pretty
colors these are the source of fireworks
right the colors you see in fireworks
are nothing more than burning salts like
this those are very nice ok let us put
them out now well take a picture and the
key for Bunsen and kerkhof was to
develop the Bunsen burner because the
only other light sources available
before that were candles and candles
gave out a characteristic yellow flame
coming from sodium you couldn't get rid
of it
so the Bunsen burner was key not for
necessarily chemistry although we use it
in chemistry but key for the Advancement
of spectroscopy ok all right so now
let's talk a little bit more
quantitatively let's talk about where
does this idea of spectroscopy come from
and let's let's thank the door and thank
Paul sorry Paul
to protect so we have to talk a little
more quantitatively that means we have
to talk about light we have to talk
about electromagnetic radiation and our
classical idea of electromagnetic
radiation is oscillating electric or
magnetic and magnetic fields so that's
why light is often called
electromagnetic or e/m radiation it is a
wave phenomena right and a wave means
that you have a localized disturbance
that moves in space and time if we've
heard on the weather report there is a
cold wave in Boston and by early next
week it will move down to New Haven
right we have all we all have in our
mind what we're thinking about right we
have a local cold disturbance in Boston
it's traveling in space and time and
sometime next week it'll arrive in New
Haven right so a wave is a localized
disturbance or a localized phenomenon
that moves in space and time what kind
of waves are you very familiar with it's
not well okay sound waves we hear that
but if you went to the beach beach water
waves right so these are clearly waves
these are waves generated by wind wind
blowing on the surface of the water or
what sorry animal waves what what sorry
animals might push the water and make
waves also in fact we can push the water
and make waves too right so for example
this little movie shows taking an object
and dipping it up and down in a pan of
water and generating water waves going
out from the source so to generate water
waves I take a little my finger maybe
and I tap repeatedly in the water and it
makes the waves if you want to generate
electromagnetic waves you take a charged
particle and you oscillate it up and
down and it generates electromagnetic
waves just like we can generate water
here but if you look at the edge here
you'll see that far away from the source
the waves look like oscillations up and
down up and down so let's take a look at
those oscillations so here I have a wave
amplitude spatial position so the wave
has high points which we call crests and
it has low points which we call troughs
the SEP you can see we have many crests
many troughs the seperation between the
crests is what we call the wavelength of
the wave the wave length tells us the
distance per oscillation of the wave and
if we're talking about light the kind of
electromagnetic radiation our eyes are
accustomed to dealing with well green
light has a wavelength of what is called
in our kinds of units for spectroscopy
500 nanometers a nanometer is ten to the
minus nine meters this is a very small
wavelength to put that in perspective a
typical human hair has a diameter of 70
micrometers so green light is 500 times
ten to the minus nine meters
typical human hair 770 times ten to the
minus six meters so typical wavelength
of green light blue-green light is a
hundred and forty times smaller than a
human hairs diameter so wavelength is
one important property of light another
and that tells us something about the
spatial properties of light another
important property of light is its time
dependence so we want to think about
timing a wave so to time a wave we might
have a stopwatch and we might want to
count how many crests go by in a given
amount of time
so you know we might turn the stopwatch
when we hit this crest
that's crest 0 then we have crest 1
crest to crest 3 crest 4 we count as
many as we want while counting how much
time is passed we make we divide
how many waves have gone past by the
time and that gives us a quantity called
the frequency the number of oscillations
per time so for a Bluegreen light the
frequency is very high typically the
conventional unit for frequency is known
as the Hertz named after the person who
discovered radio waves 1 Hertz is one
oscillation per second optical light is
measured in units of what are called
terahertz a terahertz is ten to the
twelfth Hertz or 600 terahertz is
blue-green light so that's 600 with all
of these zeroes oscillations per second
so you mentioned sound waves right sound
waves in the middle of the hearing range
for middle C 256 Hertz as opposed to
blue-green light that's a factor of ten
to the twelfth difference much much
higher frequency than sound waves there
is a fundamental relationship between
frequency and wavelength if you take
frequency and multiply it by wavelength
while frequency is oscillations per time
wavelength is distance for oscillation
the oscillation factors cancel out and
you're left with distance per time
meters per second distance per time is
speed or velocity what speed or what
velocity are we talking about here it's
the speed of light the speed of light is
about three times ten to the eighth
meters per second if we want to put that
in units that are more familiar for
driving a car this would be a hundred
and eighty six thousand miles per second
right this is the fundamental speed
limit of nature as far as we know right
now nothing can travel faster than that
speed right but that speed is given and
this is the speed of light moving in a
vacuum
when light passes through something
that's not a
Jim like a prism it typically slows down
and moves a bit slower than that okay so
this is the classical description of
electromagnetic radiation however and it
was it was all the rage everyone
believed it until the turn of the last
century in 1900 when many experiments
were performed that showed what Isaac
Newton thought in 1666 wasn't so crazy
after all
under the right conditions
electromagnetic radiation behaves like a
wave but under some other conditions
electromagnetic wave radiation behaves
like a particle so this is the quantum
mechanical or quantum description of
light light consists of localized
bundles of energy and those localized
bundles of energy we now call photons
and that name was coined by the person I
showed you I think on my second slide GN
Lewis a physical chemist right so light
under the right conditions can behave
like a wave under under other conditions
it can behave like a particle right we
all have an idea of what a particle is
like right we'll agree that this ball is
a particle but modern science says that
under the right conditions this particle
can behave like a wave and waves can do
interesting things waves can pass
through things right light passes
through glass modern physical science
also says we can be either particles or
waves if therefore says I can walk
through the wall there's not a high
probability that I can walk through the
wall but it says I can so modern science
basically set has what we call the wave
particle duality under the right
conditions something can be a wave under
other conditions it can be a particle
they're not independent you have to
combine the names together to get
something that you might call a wave
achill or a part a cycle okay so that
means light can behave like a particle
and we should be able to relate particle
properties to wave properties and there
are two particle properties that I want
to talk about only one is of real
importance in spectroscopy the first
particle property is energy the capacity
to do work the other particle property
that's interesting is what is called
momentum the ability to give an impulse
to something if you want to think about
a man momentum right if we have a big
person running in a Giffen's given speed
we say they have a large amount of
momentum if you have a smaller person
running at that same speed we say they
have less momentum because we're
thinking if they knock into us the
bigger person is going to have a bigger
force directing us so particle
properties such as energy and momentum
can be related to the wave properties in
particular the energy of a particle is
related to its characteristic frequency
so the energy of a photon is related to
the frequency of the photon the linear
momentum of a photon is inversely
related to the wavelength of the photon
where the proportionality constant is a
fundamental constant of nature known as
the Planck constant spectroscopy really
cares about that energy idea because all
of spectroscopy is nothing more than the
conservation of energy the amount of
energy you put in has to be equal to the
amount of energy you put out you get out
after you finish the process we're not
going to talk so much about this linear
momentum but that linear momentum could
play a big part in the future I
encourage you all to do a Google search
for solar sailing or light sailing
because in the future we might travel
between the planets by using the fact
that light coming in these little
bundles has a linear momentum and
therefore it can exert a full force so
instead of sailing with wind we will
sail with photons between the planets
perhaps okay so we have an idea that
light can be a wave light can be a
particle light has wavelengths light has
frequencies I'm
showing you going to show you now a
depiction of what is called the
electromagnetic spectrum this is
basically the wavelength and frequency
dependence of electromagnetic radiation
and so I'm trying to show you a part of
the electromagnetic spectrum over here
is wavelength in units of meters over
here is frequency in units of Hertz
there is no lower limit and no upper
limit to the electromagnetic spectrum
but we tend to separate this
electromagnetic spectrum into different
regions we have radio waves here which
have wavelengths on the order of a
kilometer the size of buildings we have
microwaves here which are actually what
is used in your microwave oven we have
the visible part of the spectrum here on
either side are less than visible
commonly called infrared or more than
visible so this is less energy than red
this is more energy than blue the
ultraviolet and then beyond the
ultraviolet very short wavelengths
x-rays and gamma rays and I try to show
you what the wavelength scale is over
here right radio waves the scale of
buildings microwaves the scale of humans
or butterflies infrared we're talking
about wavelengths on the order of a
needle point visible we're talking about
little animals protozoa bacteria
ultraviolet we're talking about
molecules atoms that are joined together
to form more complicated structures
x-rays and gamma rays we're talking
about atoms and atomic nuclei okay and
photon energy right the energy scales
with increasing frequency so photon
energy is increasing here our eyes are
sensitive only to what we call visible
light visible light is this part of the
spectrum ranging from very blue 400
nanometer light to very red 750
nanometer light young people can usually
see a broader part of the spectrum than
old people like myself as you get older
your spectrum range decreases so you
don't see as far in the blue
as a young person or as far in the red
as a young person so how does the
electromagnetic spectrum relate to
spectroscopy to interacting with atoms
and molecules again it's energy
conservation so what are we talking
about for spectra in the case of spectra
we have energy levels in an atom or
molecule we have a lower-lying energy
level we have a higher lying energy
level and then we apply light which we
can think of about as particles that
have certain amounts of energy if we
want those particles to do anything with
matter we have to satisfy an energy
conservation condition we have to have
that the difference in energy between
these two states e 2 minus e 1 has to be
equal to the energy of the light that we
apply otherwise the light just passes
through and does nothing at all so this
energy conservation criterion is what
determines where a spectral feature
appears because you have to have this H
u 2 1 equal to e2 minus e1 therefore
where the spectral feature appears in
frequency is just given by e2 minus e1
over H which can be related to the
wavelength like so and so what is a
spectrum show you if you analyze a
spectrum and analyzing a spectrum is
actually an art because what you're
trying to do is pattern recognition once
you analyze a spectrum you get a map of
the energy levels in an atom or molecule
and if you know the energy levels in an
atom or molecule you know how that atom
or molecule is put together you know how
that atom or molecule is interacting
with its neighbors so what kind of
interactions can you have between light
and matter there are three basic
processes and these processes are at the
heart of all spectroscopy and I'll give
you a demonstration of them in a moment
the first is what we would call
stimulated or induced absorption
the idea here is that you start with
your atom or molecule in a lower energy
state and let's understand molecules and
atoms prefer to be in lower energy
states you start with an atom or
molecule in a lower energy state you
apply light or photons that have the
right energy to satisfy that energy
conservation criteria it takes the atom
or molecule and has it undergo a
transition such that the photon is
destroyed or annihilated and by energy
conservation you're left with an atom or
molecule in the excited energy level
that's the process that is of absorption
the photon gets destroyed but energy
conservation says that the molecule is
moved from a lower energy state to a
higher energy state another process that
I'll demonstrate in a second is what is
called the mission but this is
spontaneous emission we start with an
atom or molecule in an excited state
atom or molecules don't like to be in an
excited state they want to relax they
want to go back to a lower energy state
they can do that spontaneously by
emitting a photon of the right frequency
and falling back down to the ground
state this process of spontaneous
emission often go undergoes other goes
under other names other names are
fluorescence or phosphorescence the
colors we saw from what lit the
demonstration lador was doing those
colors in the flames
they were fluorescence fluorescence is
spontaneous emission that occurs very
rapidly with high probability high
efficiency phosphorescence is
spontaneous emission that Co occurs very
slowly with low probability and low
efficiency and we're going to do a
demonstration now showing you a little
bit I'll do that well okay
showing you a little bit about
absorption and and spontaneous emission
so what do we have here we have here
five different
glass vessels five glass vessels
containing in water various dyes okay
and you can see the various dyes have
different colors because you you know
your light is able to sense which colors
are being refracted or sent back to you
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to pass different colors of light
through these dyes so we'll start with
red okay so red passing through this
first cell if you look there and I don't
know how well you can see but it
basically passes through with no
absorption light just passes straight
through and you don't see very much in
the wall of the vessel so in this case
they're that red light doesn't have the
right color to satisfy an energy
conservation condition to give you
either absorption or any kind of
emission let's try a different color
let's try green so this is a very bright
green our eyes are very sensitive to
green light because the major part of
light coming from our Sun is green
yellow right so our eyes have evolved to
be very sensitive to green yellow so
let's take this green beam and pass it
through this green beam when we pass it
through if you look no light is coming
out on this side you can see that it is
all being absorbed as it passes through
that green color is the right energy per
photon to interact with the dye and get
completely absorbed where that means
when it's absorbed it's taking dye
molecules from a lower energy state and
putting them in a higher energy State
what do they do once they get in the
higher energy State they relax they
relax by emitting light and you can see
the green beam comes in and yellow light
is coming out the side that's
fluorescing down to various states in
the dye molecule
okay so let's not use green let's
instead use now blue so this is a blue
light source about 457 nanometers blue
if we pass it through the first cuvette
you'll see that it passes through so
some is getting a
but some but certainly not as much as
the green beam a lot is passing through
we go through the next here it is
getting totally absorbed blue light is
coming in green light it's exciting the
molecules to the excited level and then
fluorescence is coming out in the color
green pass through this red cell here
again not absorbed completely and
clearly fluorescence right some of it is
absorbed going to an excited level and
then coming back down and emitting the
next one so again most of it is going
through maybe a little bit snot little
sign of fluorescence but not very much
and then the final one going through
okay but clearly being absorbed right
blue light is going through some of it
is getting absorbed without a doubt and
you see fluorescence on the side
fluorescence in a different color you
put an energy of a given photon of a
given energy the light coming out as
fluorescence has to be either that
energy or it could be less energy if
there are other energy levels that it
can decay down to so what we see here is
fluorescence fluorescence is something
that and we have here an ultraviolet
lamp
you can see when we shine the lamp on
the various dyes it starts to glow
because we're putting in enough energy
to go to an excited state to have
fluorescence occur but the fluorescence
stops as soon as we turn off the light
source fluorescence is spontaneous
emission that occurs very quickly with
high efficiency let's now look at
phosphorescence so phosphorescence I
have here a piece of phosphorescent
material now phosphorescent material
again you have to put in enough energy
per photon to go to an excited state so
it can start to fluoresce so let's start
with red light which has very low energy
per photon we shine red light on here
and now Zach will take his hand off
nothing right nothing there's not enough
enter
Jeepers photon in the red light to go to
an excited state to start to have oh
okay so let's do the red light again
let's put it here red light again not
enough energy per photon to do anything
so we don't go to the excited state we
have no emission in the form of either
fluorescence or phosphorescence now
let's use instead and ultraviolet and
will bathe Zak's hand and then Zach will
take his hand away phosphorescence it'll
last for a while right but eventually it
will go back to being a dark screen
completely but so fluorescence and let's
give an applause so fluorescence and
phosphorescence are both spontaneous
emission fluorescence occurs very
quickly with high efficiency
phosphorescence occurs not so quickly
with not so high efficiency my laser
pointer over there okay so there are
three basic processes let me turn this
off and turn this off we have stimulated
absorption we have spontaneous emission
the third process is the opposite of
stimulated absorption stimulated
emission here we start with atoms or
molecules in an excited state we apply
light of the right color to induce a
transition that light comes in and
quote-unquote tickles the molecule
causing it to fall down to a lower
energy state it emits a photon but that
first photon that started the process
continues onward so this is photon
amplification one photon goes in two
photons come out it's more than that
however it is photon cloning the photon
that comes out is an exact duplicate
of the photon that came in and this is
the basis of the device we call a laser
right laser is an acronym each letter of
the name stands for a different word
laser is an acronym for light
amplification by stimulated emission of
radiation okay so let's talk about
spectra now let's look at the spectrum
of atomic hydrogen so the spectrum of
high atomic hydrogen that we're going to
look at in a moment we have an
electrical discharge in hydrogen gas
we're going to pass it through a device
that can take the discharge light and
separate it into wavelengths we saw that
when we did that before with the white
light we got a continuous spectrum right
all the colors of the rainbow if you do
this instead with a discharge and
hydrogen you don't get white light you
get these bands which are often called
spectral lines only occurring at certain
discrete points so let's look at this
now we're going to turn on some
discharge lamps and look at the spectra
that we will see and I guess what camera
do I put here which one is it's a
Silurian VGA
okay so the lamp that is on right now is
a hydrogen lamp you all have one of
these diffraction gratings I hope if you
want to use one of these diffraction
gratings you don't look directly at the
source have the scale of wavelength
towards your eye and then look to the
right of the source and you'll see these
colors but I'm going to project these
colors for you to see so we're going to
turn on a hydrogen discharge is it on Oh
so we're going to turn on a hydrogen
discharge it glows red and now we're
going to project the spectrum the
spectrum that you get from that hydrogen
discharge not all the colors of the
rainbow discrete features a red line a
blue line a violet line just like you
see over here this is a fingerprint or
barcode for atomic hydrogen right so
this is the sort what spectroscopy is by
looking at the light coming out of that
source you can determine what is
generating the light in this case this
is the signature for hydrogen if we
switch to a different element if we
switch for example to helium the
spectral pattern is completely different
the lines are appearing in different
places we have yellow lines green lines
blue lines different from what we saw on
hydrogen it's a fingerprint right a
fingerprint for helium and finally if we
switch to a discharge of a molecule we
switch to a discharge of carbon dioxide
co2 the spectrum now is again completely
different but also here the lines are
longer sharp lines because a molecule
has other things it can do in particular
in a molecule the atoms forming the
molecules can vibrate with respect to
each other and that gives you a more
complicated spectrum so that spectrum
has encoded in it a pattern that pattern
in the case of atomic hydrogen was
analyzed at the beginning of the 1900s
the spectrum we saw for atomic hydrogen
was this the bomber visible spectrum it
represents transitions occurring between
sets of energy levels and that tells us
something about the structure of a
hydrogen atom okay so let's now talk a
little about spectroscopy and lasers and
I like to give an analogy here
spectroscopy before lasers in an analogy
with communications which is such an
important part of our lives now
spectroscopy before lasers was like this
I hope children still make this this is
a tin can telephone right two tin cans
with a string between them speak in one
end sound gets transmitted by the string
to a can on the other end this is
communication right but it's not very
flexible and you can't do it across
country that's for sure that's sort of
spectroscopy before the laser
spectroscopy after the laser totally
different we can do many many different
things we can do them much more quickly
much more accurately much better and we
can therefore learn a lot more about
atoms and molecules by doing that let's
understand some of the special prob oh
how old is the laser when was the laser
invented 70s is close it was actually
invented for somebody else 1960 exactly
this is the inventor the it so in theory
it was proposed many years before but in
1960 may 6 nineteen sixteenth 1960 this
person had a
research company used research
laboratory made the first laser which
he's holding in his hands and what he is
holding is this he is holding a Ruby
rhod ruby has chromium doped you know in
a crystalline gem aluminum oxide matrix
surrounding it as a flash lamp that
flash lamp is what excites the Ruby the
chromium atoms in Ruby to an excited
state and then by doing the right things
by putting mirrors on either side you
can start to have a laser action occur
so it's very simple to make don't make
it at home right but it was at the time
a great discovery everybody agreed this
was a great discovery but very soon
everybody realized that what do we do
with this great discovery it was called
a solution in search of a problem this
has changed because now that laser has
led to at least eight Nobel prizes in
physics and chemistry it's now a
multi-billion dollar industry and it has
become a solution for many problems how
many of you have a laser at home many of
you probably do right if you have a DVD
or CD device at home the information on
here is written with a laser and it's
read back with a laser but let's talk
about some of the special properties of
laser light so what's the first special
property about laser light its
monochromatic it's single color so if we
for example look at the spectrum of
solar light so what I'm showing you is
intensity versus wavelength the yellow
curve is the spectrum that you would see
from a satellite above Earth's
atmosphere you can see it spans the
visible part of the spectrum it has
ultraviolet it has a lot of infrared the
blue curve is the spectrum you measure
at sea level on the surface of the earth
where the ultraviolet has been blocked
out by ozone in the atmosphere
and we get these deep absorption bands
coming from atmospheric gases like water
which is good and carbon dioxide which
is bad right global warming right but
those are the absorptions you would see
at sea level from various atmospheric
gases even a run-of-the-mill laser and
this is a run-of-the-mill laser here
this is what is known as a helium neon
laser it produces a red beam of light
which I'm showing you on the door here
this laser has a spectral bandwidth that
is a straight line on this plot
extremely narrow band and that way if
you want to do spectroscopy you don't
have broad sources of light you have
narrowband sources of light that you can
tune through transitions and measure
them very precisely this is the basis of
high resolution spectroscopy it is also
the basis now of our time standards our
definition of the second is based on
transitions occurring in atoms and
molecules so the first property is it's
highly monochromatic the second property
is it's highly coherent and I like to
show this picture the light coming out
of a laser exactly the same color all in
phase the light coming out of a
conventional source miss mash I like to
have the analogy right this is a
precision marching band where everyone
is marching and stepping in phase this
is Yael's precision marching band which
is a is defined to be a scatter band
right on purpose but here we're
marchings stepwise coming with the light
coming out of a laser why is this useful
this is useful for something called
interferometry we take one beam of light
we break it into two and recombine them
after we've gone through different paths
what does this do this gives us a
process known as interference so if we
look at one of these movies of water
waves two water sources now when they
meet this is interference where the
water sources are positive you have
constructive interference
where they're both negative you have
again constructive interference negative
but when where it one is positive and
one is negative they add together to
give you a zero so this is the
phenomenon of interference it provides a
very precise way to measure distances
and distance between these two arms why
is that useful there are two of these in
our country right now these are known as
laser interferometry gravity wave
observatories LIGO this is the LIGO
facility in Livingston Louisiana there's
a similar one in Hanford Washington they
consist of arms that are 4 kilometers
long they are trying to detect gravity
waves they succeeded just this year in
detecting gravity waves right gravity
waves are the are the screams of dying
stars and the way you detect that is
looking for very small differences in
the arms of these interferometers so
laser light is very coherent laser light
is highly directional right this laser
pointer you know stays a very small beam
as I scan it over the ceiling of this
room laser beams can stay highly
collimated highly directional and this
is useful for distance ranging remote
sensing and even material ablation or
material cutting so money of us are
familiar with radar radio detection and
ranging it's what the police catch us
with on i-95 even better is lidar light
detection and ranging right light
detection and raging is laser based
shooting out laser at a car seeing how
long it takes for the beam to bounce
back another way this is used is to
measure distances every day throughout
the United States at several places and
throughout the world we shoot pulses of
light at the moon and time how long it
takes for the light to reach the moon
reflect off and bounce back we do that
to measure the distance to the moon we
do this repeatedly every day for
years and years and years and what we
have discovered is that the moon is
leaving us every year the moon is
getting on the order of one and a half
inches further away from us and
eventually the moon will depart from
Earth but it will be a long time so it's
used for distance detection another is
high brightness the Sun and this is a
measure of intensity per frequency the
Sun has a very low intensity per
frequency run-of-the-mill helium neon
laser like this beam this red beam here
13 orders of magnitude bigger more
powerful laser even more orders of
magnitude bigger 20 orders of magnitude
difference in spectral intensity the
most powerful lasers right now petawatts
10 to the 15 watts to put that in
perspective the Millstone nuclear power
station in Connecticut unit number 3
reactor number 3 has an output a thermal
output of three point six five times ten
to the ninth watts that's much much
smaller orders of magnitude smaller than
the power coming out of that laser on
the other hand the Millstone power plant
generates electrical power continuously
this laser is a pulse that is on for a
brief second a brief part of a second
but during that brief instant in time it
puts out more energy than many power
plants so lasers can put out a lot of
energy you can do materials fabrication
you can certainly burn through steel
plates very easily the biggest lasers
you'll find in the world that are a
place in Livermore California called the
National Ignition facility where you
have more than a hundred and ninety two
laser beams that are putting in being
put into one one place in one chamber
where they're trying to ignite something
it's not firewood they're trying to
ignite nuclear fusion they're trying to
ignite the power of the Sun to provide a
environmentally friendly source of power
another property of laser light is that
you can generate very short pulses the
shortest pulses of laser light right now
that have been generated are on the
order of a hundred at Oh seconds and add
a second is ten to the minus 18 seconds
that's a one with 17 zeros in front of
it and then a decimal point in front of
that this allows us to basically do stop
action photography but ultra fast stop
action photography and one of the
pioneers and this was Ahmed zewail who
unfortunately passed away about two
months ago but this is the time scale
that is now open to chemistry running
from milliseconds to nanoseconds to
picoseconds to femtoseconds let's put
this in perspective every day hundreds
of times a day each of us blinks how
long does it take to blink
a second if you blinked if it took a
second we would call you doing a
microsleep it typically takes on the
order of 50 you know a couple of hundred
milliseconds so 0.1 seconds to blink you
know this is three orders of magnitude
smaller this is another several orders
of magnitude smaller this is you could
say it's in a blink of an eye but that
would not be true this is really really
short so short that we can basically
stop molecules when they're vibrating
stop molecules when they're rotating and
understand them completely understand
their dances their motions completely I
wanted to tell you a little about what
we do in my lab but I'll go through it
very quickly we're interested in
fundamental chemical processes a very
simple chemical process and one of the
most common ones in chemistry and
biology is a proton or a hydrogen atom
jumping back and forth between two sites
mediated by what is called a hydrogen
bond which isn't a real chemical bond
but is very much an electrostatic
interaction and to understand or to
probe this we are using some of the
special properties of lasers lasers are
so intense that you can have what are
called multi photon processes rather
than one photon coming in getting
absorbed or a minute you can
simultaneously have multi photons coming
in and doing more complicated processes
and this shows diagrammatically what one
of those processes might look like
another thing we're doing in my
laboratory is to understand molecular
chirality molecules come in a
right-handed form and a left-handed form
they're mirror images of each other the
two molecules that are mirror images
have typically identical physical or
chemical properties unless you can put
them in an environment that can
distinguish handedness and you don't
have to look much further than your
right or left hand to realize that
biology is very much able to distinguish
handedness right hand from left hand so
light it turns out can also be
have this property of handedness so we
are we are interacting light that has
right or left handedness with molecules
that have right or left handedness to
understand fundamental properties that
distinguish a right-handed molecule from
the left-handed molecule and so my time
is pretty much up I wanted to just end
with this this final slide again
thanking my students for helping me to
do all the demos here and thanking you
for your attention